one of only 31 people to ever walk the
planet with at least 10,000 yards
rushing in the National Football League
from right here in Nashville Tennessee
could see it very popular here in this
town very popular is this a little bit
no well I mean you sat down you asked me
what I thought about Nashville for the
draft and I'll repeat it right here
not only has Nashville knocked it out of
the park but Nashville has definitely
changed the way the NFL is gonna look at
housing the draft from now on and if
this is now like a bidding process like
the Super Bowl as you know when teams
and cities bid for the Super Bowl more
often than not the ones that do it right
are put in a rotation where they come
back around there's no question
Nashville is gonna be in a drive I'm so
pleased to hear they doubt I served on
the committee to help get the draft here
there's some videos here and they're not
nothing major sure but this is a gem of
a city and and you know I think the
Predators had their run about two
seasons ago yeah and it was it was
magical was just beautiful on Broad
Street Broadway and all the bars the
lots parties and this the the energy the
weather everything was perfect for it
and last night to steam the scene though
the stage to set up everything was just
so well done look good it was amazing
they named her city ever good we have us
we have a set of Tootsie's well not in
Tootsie's but we we created a set that
comes out into Broadway and and it was a
brilliant idea whoever came with that
need to shake the hand of the person of
people the NFL Network they they draped
the scaffolding mm-hmm in lavender
bricks to make it look like it's part of
Tootsie's that they put out there huh
it's awesome
and the shot down Broadway of the neon
lights behind is just breathtaking and
the reason why I say that this is a
difference maker and then we'll get to
some draft and some football stuff with
you Eddie Georgia is the reason why it's
a difference maker is in the st. in you
know in the way that Chicago was amazing
mhm
it was in Grant Park the city looked
amazing it rained one time but it
is really amazing and the way
Philadelphia was remarkable - or they
transformed he's in the museum steps in
Ben Franklin Parkway and last year was
wild to be in a stadium that size for
the Dallas Cowboys those are all places
that needed to be transformed to have a
part here you go daga those were all
places where you needed to have these
tents created that had things like say
hey come and watch see the Lombardi
Trophy put your put your head on on on a
uniform with a head on it take your
picture I haven't seen one of those yet
in Nashville because you're gonna have
to create that stuff right it was
dropped into a vibrant living partly
thoroughfare already that happens 365
that's why people write all over the
world come here to have that experience
so now I think that's what I mean by
transforming is the league's gonna look
to see okay what spot that already
exists that's famous for existing in the
manner in which it exists lay it up and
we put the draft in can we close off can
we make secure and do it that way but
that's why I think it why I say
Nashville's transforming the way that
they look it really was I mean butch
spirited who is part of the chamber
Commerce the Celts are here to help
bring a lot of events to our our city I
did a fantastic job of that I mean he
really worked hard and trying to
convince the guys the league office to
come bring the event here and just has
just been awesome and it is what what 20
million dollars this off of last night
to write the our economy here it's it's
it's it's a wonderful deal in there and
I think it bodes well for us in the
future for bring other events like maybe
the World Cup won the World Cup games or
hopefully a Super Bowl one day we could
get the right venue and I mean this the
city's just exploded over the last 23
years as I've been hearing them I'm just
really proud of Nashville
whether you've been able to do this week
by the way that's an applause line for
everybody yeah Nashville right there I
mean if you wanna like Nashville it's
also a testament to Nashville that yeah
that they're gonna make it a destination
certainly for the draft Eddie George
here on the Rich Eisen show you're in a
locker room
you hear quarterback that just gets
drafted by your team and he's pissed
because others like passed on him you do
like that oh I like that was that was me
in fact 96 yeah I was 14 mm-hmm and the
Oilers were supposed to pick me at
number nine mm-hmm
to quarterback two running backs went
ahead of me timbi I could put two good
okay Lawrence Phillips right and they
traded loud that slot to go down I think
to maybe 20 22 mmm and I was like oh wow
this is gonna get be a long night and of
course all the cameras come up to me and
it's trying to see my react you read the
green room I was in the green room in
New York okay and you know I'm sitting
there trying to smile and inside I'm
just like oh my gosh this is gonna be an
awful day seeing that a Michigan man was
taken before no question and how he and
he ended my undefeated season and ran
for 300 yards against yeah I remember
yeah I'm waiting for another beer to
come omen it's coming in in the next
century or so okay thank you but not not
even not anytime soon but uh they wind
up coming back up to 14 got me at 14 and
I was really happy but I told my agent
when I got the stage at tackle this hand
I said listen whatever you do just get
me in camp on time and I'll take care of
the rest and that led to me having a
working your season a few Pro Bowl
seasons in a row so this is a good thing
for Dewayne Haskins cuz he felt slighted
from the Heisman mm-hmm and didn't get
enough love there I thought he's got
more votes as a Heisman Trophy at 50
touchdowns - come on man come on against
the league competition and now with the
draft and with I don't know what the
Giants were thinking but I thought he
was definitely going to be in New York
giant but that's what you have to have
he's gonna come in with a chip when he
says it I'm coming in with the chip on
his shoulder
I'm on my shoulder I'm pretty sure he's
like let's just sign me today
it doesn't matter and now he's gonna
face the team twice a year right yeah oh
this is gonna be beautiful but there's
no there's no one in the locker room
that's thinking right now hey you know
he should be excited to be here and not
have a chip on his shoulder
now you want that okay
for Washington look you want a
quarterback you're chipping a joke right
you know from the area to his family's
got to be ecstatic
Washington's gotta be ecstatic so we had
him on the show last week and he's got a
lot on the ball he's a sharp sharp kid
smart kid he would not say the word
Michigan said that night I pointed that
out to him twice he said that right and
I'm like what if the lines taken and he
says I will say that I play in Detroit I
know like so he had it was funny you
know he's engaging that's kind of like
you need to have somebody who's who can
you know play around and understand that
you know bond and there's a certain
aspect to being a face front figure yeah
I like it a lot I really said all fronts
and that's what's shocking to me is that
he didn't have any red flags and right
opinion off the field I mean we know his
body of work on the field so I know his
family I know him personally he's
matured into a fine young man and what a
way for his and I will bring this up and
then we'll drop it the way that he came
in in the big house JT Barrett who
probably got every snap under the planet
right yes because he is the all-time
he's he's a goat at Ohio State he goes
down in the big house and I told him
this when he was on the phone and I'm
like I thought that game was a wrap
because here's the backup and that kid
was like oh man where did that throw
come from no probably hoping that man
hurt JT so forth right so which which
which what better way to prove your you
can come off the bench you can do this
through natural ability in whatever
preparations that you have he coached he
talked up coach day and all that stuff
sounds good all right now we will drop
it Eddie George you're on the Rich Eisen
show right here on the program and then
you know obviously what's going on here
with the Titans what what do you think
about what's happening with this
franchise here they took a defensive
tackle last night not obviously the
sexiest pick but a very crucial position
right here what do you think about the
Titans right now I think they're headed
in the right direction
Mike Rabil came in with a lot of
I guess questions in terms of his youth
where he came from and so forth but I
think he's the great fit for what
they're trying to become and now he's
building that culture that they're
looking for you know for for the type of
defense that he wants to have and he's
accustomed to having he wants some guys
that are gonna be Fist fighters they're
gonna be nasty in the trenches and based
off of the highlights that I've seen we
didn't see this kid play last year
because he had a torn ACL right based
off what I see when he's healthy he's
very disruptive and had he been healthy
but had been top 5 so they're banking on
the fact that he's gonna come back
healthier probably you know did their
due diligence when his name there's
probably in line to to be healthy again
and they're saying he can be a true
difference maker on the defensive line
because they're in a conference where
they have to face the Shawn Watson twice
Andrew Luck
now Nick Foles balls twice and these are
quarterbacks that can get it done so
they're gonna have to get heat up front
and that's what they need it so I kind
of know the answer this question and so
I'll ask it anyway because I'm gonna be
eager to hear it how do you like the way
Derek Henry runs the football team or I
like the second half of the year I mean
it was dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde well quit or
we could just say clicked you know
something really clicked for him yeah he
ran with oh my gosh
more passion desire he ran with more
assets of urgency do you think that's
the Derek Henry I know that's the bear
alarm that's it but that's how he ran
Alabama he did I that's how he ran in
high school so it took him some time to
figure it out he was a backup behind the
DeMarco Murray for the first two years
so he had to accept that role so he got
accustomed to to running that way and
trying to hit the home run every single
time when he should allow the game to
come to him and once he got settled and
being in that role of saying okay I got
time to setup my runs I can impose my
will I don't have to score a touchdown
every time he's just become a beast a
man among men right I mean that 99 yard
run
how would he stiff arms if you use it
also one of the greatest 99-yard run-up
ever it is only two guys never do it
right and that was Tony Gore sitting him
but my god that was that's incredible
yeah I'm sorry it's his team yeah I
don't you see
your Jaguar fan is not in great
Jacksonville Jaguar D fits Jalen Ramsey
Oh jack all these guys still getting
stiffed armed to this day I love it I
love twisted into Jacksonville's ribs I
love it well three times and one at one
year 99 remember that everybody else
League but us so this Duval County fried
Eddie George today and now he's that's
thing I love about you Eddie and the one
thing I want to bring up here is you
know when the NFL Network started you
were already six seven years into your
career 2003 and my favorite favorite
matchup was you versus the Ravens and
Ray Lewis waiting in the hole fans are
already clapping to say I feel the same
way where did that come from what was
where did the rivalry yes sir 96 we both
in 96 draft oh man that was a good trap
look it up Keyshawn Johnson was one I
was 14 Jonathan Ogden was for Kevin
Hardy Simeon rice Terrell Terrell Owens
yeah Ray Lewis was also in the draft so
we kind of knew each other by going a
different award banquets and so forth
right and became really good friends
after a night of drinking and talking
crap to each other we just stayed in
touch and then we got drafted into the
same conference and we wound up seeing
each other so both our teams early in
our careers are really bad you know they
couldn't win four games and were really
trying to find out who they were they
moved from Cleveland to Baltimore we
move it from from Houston to Nashville
and really trying to get settled so
right around 2000 when we really got
good we feel like really figure out who
we were and we were really good friends
off the field but on the field oh man if
I killed him on the field great and he
felt the same way I mean we were willing
to die on the field while you were just
it was nasty it would be you running the
way you ran in him coming into the hole
the way that he did and you would let
him know after play I mean you were
barking at him yeah it's not that is
there any stock didn't sighs about to
say is there any any story specific
story that's safe for work that you
could tell from that share well people
I'd say we're talking about that the
playoff game and in Baltimore yes sir
that's a good one yeah well he there was
an article that came out in Sporting
News about his career and what happened
so forth and I was in that he said well
Eddie changed Eddie George's career
after I laid a hit on him and a playoff
game I'm thinking okay what is this when
I ever go out of the game and when you
hit me or laid me out that was won in
the Memorial Stadium in 97 that was a
good hit mm-hmm but I'm like okay all
right when I see you again we're gonna
find out you know and lo and behold we
split the divisions at that time they
went to the air we're all in one
division a month with the innocence
right right
black and blue that's right but then
they went to the north we went to the
south and lo and behold
no oath read we draw the Ravens going
into Baltimore I said ah yes this is the
time so I was very patient in and
waiting but in the first half I suffered
a dislocated shoulder mm-hmm Steve
throws a pick every picks it off I go
behind them I try to strip the ball land
on my shoulder public I come out I'm
like oh damn yeah like I can't miss this
game but my shoulder is completely out
and I'm on the sidelines I'm banging the
bench because I'm upset I'm still out
remember then they said Eddie you gotta
calm down we got to pop it back in I
said oh that's right so they pop it back
in and there's a moment where you just
kind of feel where the glitches are and
your shoulder and to see if it's gonna
slip back out or if there's any pain so
I can kind of manage it and I had to
judge whether I was going to come out of
the game get a shot or get it wrap it up
right right so they were like listen we
got to make a decision you know what are
you gonna do what do you know it was
paced up and down the sidelines I said
strap them
and let's go okay silly take me lock go
strap it up and I came out and I was
focused and we were going back and forth
and then I think in the third quarter
all right or the fourth quarter that
moment happened
I saw him our eyes met your eyes met on
the field well good luck yeah the hole
opened up going to the right he comes
through our eyes met that's like okay
now's your time to lead me out
now's this is the moment we're supposed
to own me let's see what happens on this
result and everything in me man he came
up high I caught him by the throat and
then tried to drive his head through the
turf and then got up and we just said
whatever he had to say to each other and
and that was it but that was a game rich
that I felt like I can go out today and
still play because of the emotional
energy that I had but we felt it yeah my
legacy was on the line you know and I
felt laughter you know you felt
disrespected and that's the type of wars
that we had but today we were he was in
Nashville not too long ago it was smoked
cigars and talking about having a
podcast together talking business
together that would be great yeah yeah
absolutely
I was loved to be a guest on that new
love you they'll be a host on I would
love to try that yeah let's do this
that's this real seriously let's talk
about okay yeah that would be great yeah
if you could you already have some
download lathers right over there and
just two extra to describe to the people
in the radio audience who aren't seeing
this to show just how Nashville does
know how to hit the moment as you were
telling that story the Sun was going in
and out of the clouds and was getting
like a great scene set as you share goes
down just as you're telling a story and
then it comes out Nashville really knows
how to set the scene Matt great to see
you at EQ and rate doing a pod that
would be Eddie George 27 27 on both
Instagram and on Twitter four-time Pro
Bowl or Heisman Trophy winner Eddie
George right here on the rich eyes
before I let you go did you vote for
collar for
no you voted for Twain for the for the
Hajj I won't say who I voted for
oh come on no I got me in trouble before
in these parts I uh
when 97 and I voted for Charles Woodson
over Peyton Manning and they grilled me
here at Tennessee probably still do well
you know years it's 20 years ago but
they stood no no they hold on they still
talk about 96 we played them in the
Citrus Bowl game that really didn't
matter how you did right I'm still
hearing about everywhere I go we stopped
you on the goal line like the Citrus
Bowl borne jacket the ring good job
whatever you can't you can't be blamed
for making the right choice by choosing
a Michigan man for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app